this is a bogey Brian John Joseph was
talking about a on drogas podcast about
a fight some crazy fight you're in yeah
do you know about this you rent when
were told you identify it
let me hear this I I was invited I was
like hopefully we get along and have a
[ __ ] Toby you know Brian's a crazy
[ __ ] I tell story you know that
whole school down there was a fun
III wanted to tell the story about Brian
because he write down yeah [ __ ] he's
hilarious
so it's cuz accent tells me he beats
people pretty hard Tony our team is one
of the senior students a master Troy
another guy will call him Chuck but he's
with the government now he's a [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] so they always used to
go around and and and wanna fight
bounces and all this [ __ ] that was what
they did they would [ __ ] fight the
biggest scariest looking [ __ ]
and just destroyed him so blue worked I
said his name sorry cro-mags and we took
him out security with us in case we had
problems or whatever so it was like
everything always went smooth so one
time I used to work at all the
underground hip-hop clubs in New York so
my friend was doing a party and it was
all [ __ ] deep Brooklyn heads [ __ ]
like homeboys and [ __ ] like the real
deal this hip-hop club and I take Brian
another dude from the school and Tony
and we go over there and Brian is in the
middle of the [ __ ] dance floor doing
the funky [ __ ] white boy nerd dance
and all these [ __ ] and the floor just
opens up and he's [ __ ] black [ __ ]
hip-hop crazy [ __ ] homeboys are like
yo look at this [ __ ] white boy
like it's bugging and he don't give a
[ __ ] he's seriously like a [ __ ] piss
ative to roll with so then I might go I
gotta go but listen man I know what
y'all [ __ ] do don't start no
[ __ ] please it's my friend's club so I
get home go to sleep wake up the next
day I get a [ __ ] phone call yo like
he didn't know that they were with me so
I killed it was these three [ __ ]
karate experts in the club
tonight they beat up all my [ __ ]
bouncers dude it was [ __ ] crazy like
and one bouncer walked up and started
some [ __ ] with Tony was trying to talk
to a girl whatever and and then like you
know this guy is all on the juice rips
off his shirt like [ __ ] Tony throws a
kick [ __ ] dislocates the guy's
[ __ ] knee cap and then the first
mutiny the melee just ensued any it was
just constant these [ __ ] huge
bouncers coming at him and Brian Sipe I
[ __ ] Brian could fight Brian is uh
you know nothing he's a comedian but he
could throw down and then Brian just
told me this because I didn't hear the
other part he goes yeah then all of a
sudden I'm [ __ ] whacking these dudes
and us
we're fighting these guys and then this
[ __ ] gigantic [ __ ] like I was
just like a little [ __ ] baby in his
arms lifts me up and carries me out the
[ __ ] door and throws me across this
car and I look and I turn around and I'm
ready to go and then Brian says and I
look and it's this [ __ ] crazy white
dude with a [ __ ] scar from one end of
his face down his throat and he points
that behind it goes don't even think
about it and like Brian was like yo well
my friend called me up the next days
like these [ __ ] and I call him
up and I'm my Brian the [ __ ] did you do
man I told you guys to [ __ ] keep
chilis like y'all these bouncers were
[ __ ] and you know it was he's he's
he's a character like I said I was at
his first comedy show ever he lived a
wild of life in his young days yeah I
met him after all that stuff I met him
when he was more calm I met him in the
90s yeah yeah yeah they were in anyway I
wish I wish I wish I was crazier then
and that makes me sound like a tough guy
which I never was but I did get in I I
did that that story is funny because
what really was going on as we were at
the club we were kind of drinking and I
never looked for fights I never you know
but when you're young and you're
flirting
your own mortality you're over an issue
and this is before jiu-jitsu I would you
know I've got wrestled and I was
obsessed with Taekwondo I don't want to
only hit tennis balls against the wall
you want to play what I say for me being
the the [ __ ] that I am but but at least
I did go to tournaments and I back then
you did fight you did try to knock each
other out Taekwondo like when you're
like in tournaments you you people get
knocked down you get you get knocked out
and you seen you do kick people and you
do and my teacher was a boxer so I was
hitting mitts and stuff I'd have a bunch
of green belt
well yeah but so I I was obsessed with
it and I tried to be the guy I'm not
which is be a real fighter right but in
this particular case we were there in
these [ __ ] two dudes I'm with my
buddy and I'm just there to try to pick
up girls and this [ __ ] guy rips his
shirt off and I remember going that's
the best body I've ever seen he wasn't
even the bouncer he was just this big
huge muscular guy and then my buddy is
standing in front of him and this fight
kind of breaks out over here this kind
of shoving that and he looks at my buddy
and he pushes my buddy
and so my buddy just goes bop bop bop
and like just catches him and didn't the
guy next to him he pulled his shirt off
and he had the best again I went is such
a good fun and he came at me you know
and then I you know I he wasn't a
fighter you know and I was I was doing
that yeah yeah but I was so jealous of
how big and muscular and handsome it
added to my might my insecurities and my
you know anyway and so I lived when I
hit him instead of fighting back he he
grabbed his face yeah
you know it wasn't what I thought it
would be but the guy the truth the
forget all that stuff that what really
happened to me was as I'm fighting this
guy and then this other guy the the it
became up melee the [ __ ] I did I got
grabbed by a giant man who started
running me out and my buddy who's a
slick [ __ ] he goes get him out
cuz he was gonna get thrown out but he
was pretending to help the guy throw me
out of my [ __ ] house oh I saw him
hitting him let's go no I'm helping him
and because they were gonna try to throw
him out so he ran out with him as he's
yelling at me pretending yeah you piece
of [ __ ] get him out yeah and the guy
took me I never forgot this but this is
not an exaggeration from the door I
remember he threw me and I went oh I'm
telling you this this is not I I flew
over the sidewalk and on to the car
landed for real like think about that
how big is a New York sidewalk he threw
me eight seven I don't know what it is
but he I went I remember going through
the air and I landed on the hood of the
car and I turned around I was I was I
was in a frenzy and I was yeah yeah you
know you know and I and I did I saw this
giant tear and I've ever had this scar
and he was older he was probably yeah
you know 38mm and without but a but a
man yeah a bear a bear and then there
was nothing I might might Taekwondo is
no good here get on the stand your high
school wrestling Debra you're a hundred
and fifty fiver or whatever I was I
would've gotten [ __ ] and I did he
said don't think about it and not in in
that moment I went he did sobered up in
a way oh okay yeah no problem
we're not mad anymore bigness is
fascinating yeah that kind of bigness
the way the body building stuff to me
when I was when you when you spend your
time enough time even now with boxing
and stuff if I see some giant muscle guy
yeah all muscular who really spends time
on I'm not I'm gonna fight that guy the
guy I'm not gonna fight is the athlete
the guy I'm afraid of his the young dude
who who's got his ears or he's got a
neck I look at the neck and hand the
neck is a real picture like I'm gonna
punch him in the head and it has not got
a go yet and also by the way have you
afraid of everybody calves
yeah Judith eyes are a big if guys got a
big ass you're gonna lose or or he's
just a dude there are plenty of guys who
look like nothing who will change your
whole life they're the ones by the way
Bowie
John Joseph John Joseph that's the real
deal why
he's real say I'm not I love that he
says I'm crazy enough nothing it wasn't
it wasn't it wasn't I wasn't fighting
the money with a family of a pudding
boarding school I wasn't [ __ ] that guy
that's the guy in the lower Eastside who
used to meet me at Houston Street
because he had to walk me to his house
on Ludlow cuz I that's how the lower he
said he grew up with no family he grew
up they called him mighty wet he in jail
he went to Spofford well John grew up
harder than anybody I knew and John in
1985 1986 1987 when all that none of you
were born in the Lower East Side
John when the Lower East Side when the
expression was a her adventurous you
could have and you be your bold see your
crazy and dear dead John lived down
there and I met people through John from
Hell's Angels too you name it who I mean
everybody respected John and everybody
knew what John was capable yeah John was
real and John had they be true street
cred like that that accent and all that
that's he grew up for real
John had tattoos on his body in 1987 you
didn't know anybody who had tattoos John
recovered and John would shred it built
like a brick [ __ ] and would wear
overalls only and walk down the street
in the Lower East Side and was a fun and
was a vegetarian was a Hari Krishna at
13 cuz that's all he had so John John is
a man with tremendous character I love
him there's that's one of the best
people I know people who know the less
people they have the ability to quickly
well he didn't have a choice so there's
a difference you guys are trained and
guys like that who grew up really grew
up on the street yeah really squatted in
buildings really had no family yeah
really had here's what I wanted to say
this about him because it's important I
saw John when John had no money John
would never take money like you you
could never lend John money I don't give
a [ __ ] how broke he was I remember one
time it was a well it was the wintertime
and John had no money no no money at all
and I said what are you gonna do any
goes I'll figure it out
and there was a guy there who was a
homeless guy who John saw we was too
cold and John had five dollars and John
needed that five dollars he really did
and he gave it to the guy and then John
gave him his coat that's for real yeah
John gave his coat in the wintertime
because John didn't want to see because
he knew this homeless guy and John
didn't want to see him called I've seen
that [ __ ] give when it really
counted I've never done that in my life
so I've never even when it really hurt
I've given I give to money and I give to
everyone but I never get god I don't
know who I am when I don't know who I am
in those situations you've never given a
thing you didn't know you're gonna be
able to get back yeah but I can't get it
back
no I've never given anything that cost
me yeah I've never been in that position
I don't know who I am he knows who he
people that I find in fat people that
have been to prison and grew up really
really hard they actually are some of
the most empathetic people you'll ever
meet in your entire life
don't listen to the whole store like
well he's in jail well y-yeah well what
happened they want to know it all
because they know a lot of people that
have put in situation's out of their
control and got caught up yeah you can
get caught up yeah there are certain
cesare your friend what are you gonna do
when you have no other choices all of us
like to look down on people that steal
but if you have nothing and no choices
you're gonna [ __ ] do what you ever
you have to do yep I'll tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]